The next thing that I want to talk about in texture
optimizations is the concept of mipmapping,
is understanding what mipmaps are and why they're needed
is of vital importance.
Because mipmaps can have a direct impact
on how your project performs.
And understanding how you can manipulate mipmaps
can allow you to perform some really amazing performance
adjustments without having to sacrifice
the quality of the final rendered pixels.
Now, mipmaps are automatically generated
when you import any texture into Unreal Engine 5,
granted that that texture meets the power of two requirements
in the x and the y-axis.
When you import a texture behind the scenes,
Unreal is going to generate what's known as a mipchain.
Now, a mipchain contains multiple levels
of the same image, with each level
being half the resolution of the level before it.
In the image on our screen in front of us,
we can see a texture that is at a size of 4,096.
And then the next mip down would be 2,048, and then
1,024, 512, 256, 128, all the way down to 4 by 4.
The reason this is done is so that when a texture is
viewed very close to the camera,
we can view the highest resolution version of it.
And then as that camera and then as that texture
gets further and further away from the camera,
we can utilize a lower and lower resolution
version of it, which helps us not only
make that texture blend with the detail and the background
better, but also use less rendering performance.
Now, this is an example of mipmapping in action.
On the left-hand side, we have a texture
with mipmapping on.
And the right-hand side, same texture, this time
with mipmapping turned off.
And the main difference we can see here
is that as this texture starts to go from the foreground
to the mid-ground to the background,
notice that on the left-hand side,
the texture seems to converge fairly nicely.
We can kind of make out some of the detail,
as we would expect, especially if we were looking
at something in the real world.
However, on the right-hand side,
as the texture starts to go off into the distance,
while things do converge, there is a lot of noise in there.
And it makes it very hard to focus on anything.
And this is why mipmapping is so important.
Not only does mipmapping help your textures, especially
textures in the distance, look like they blend together,
it also makes things cheaper to render
for those textures that are viewed in the distance.
Now, you might be thinking, well, what do you mean by
makes it cheaper to render?
Well, this is what I'm talking about.
Here we have the ancient temple demo,
and we've taken that texture from our first slide
and applied it to all of the static meshes in the world.
As you can see, the 4096 version of our mipmap
or the highest resolution of that mipmap
isn't actually utilized all the time.
In fact, we're more looking at 2048, 512, 128, and 256.
This is really important to understand,
is oftentimes when you want to go utilize an 8K texture
or even a 4K texture, the only way
to really see that whole version mipmap
is to view that texture very, very close.
Let's take a look at this inside of the editor in action.
So here I have a spectral texture set up
that's 1024 by 1024.
And let's take a look at the texture in the background
here as I start to get close to the one in the foreground.
Notice that the cube is going to be changing as I
get closer and closer to it.
We're going to 512, 1024 by 1024.
But notice as soon as I start to back up just even
a little bit, we're going to start getting that 512,
and then we're going to start getting
the 256 and then the 128.
So again, mipmapping is responsible for what
you're seeing or that transition
between the various levels of that texture.
And if your texture meets the power of two requirements
and the x and the y-axis, you'll
have no problems actually using it
because Unreal will do this for you
all behind the scenes on import.